who is one of the five mega diverse
countries those are the most biodiverse
countries on earth and proves like that
because it's got a very arid coast with
a very rich offshore current the
Humboldt Current then you've got the
Andes Mountains with lots of deep
valleys up to snow capped mountains and
then you go down into the Amazon
rainforest and that create a whole load
of micro climates and ecosystems with a
huge diversity of animals and plants in
them the manu national park is located
in southeastern Peru in the Amazon basin
most of the park is rainforest
rob williams of the Zoological Society
of Frankfurt Germany heads a project
that seeks to help preserve this
ecosystem a dozen species of reptiles
live here Caymans can grow to six meters
in length countless species of mammals
also live in minus among them capybaras
the world's largest rodents the
extensive dense forest has not been
fully explored it no doubt still holds
many secrets people also live within the
National Park indigenous groups such as
the matcha Ginga Rob Williams and his
team visit them regularly today they're
talking to the children about how
important it is to take care of the
world they live in the Amazon ecosystem
outside forces are about to encroach
ever more on their world the challenge
for these communities and we're just
really trying to help them will find
their way in this is to see what they
can do so they can maintain the
traditional way of living for those who
want to live that way and those who want
to earn money live in the monetary
economy outside the park can also have a
foot in that world and and that's the
challenge for each individual and for
the community as a whole the people here
have electricity for a couple of hours a
day it comes from solar panels or
generators it's an opportunity to watch
television many families have cleared
small plots in the forest to grow crops
such as cassava but most of the matcha
Ganga lived just like many generations
of their ancestors before as hunters
fishermen and gatherers
the older generation grew up without any
contact with the outside world in Manu
humans and nature appear to be in
balance about a thousand machi Ganga
live in the National Park their number
doubles every 19 years what effect does
this growing population have on the
natural resources here these people need
protein they get that by hunting them
together by fishing this way is very
sustainable and yes they don't have
refrigeration here they fish what they
need to eat that day there's no point in
catching tons of fish there's no market
for selling it they share when they
catch but it's you know he catches a one
of the large catfish now that will feed
his family today and look for Ruby some
left over for the people around them as
well and so they don't need any more
than my fish is not always available
forest animals offer another important
source of protein for the matcha Ganga
only the men go hunting with bow and
arrow like their fathers and
grandfathers before them it might be
easier with guns but the park
administration persuaded the hunters to
do without firearms so they wouldn't
kill too many animals too quickly then
what you can gain know their hunting
grounds very well today these men are
after a woolly monkey the trees are tall
here and the branches dense so they
don't have a clear aim
after four hours of being chased the
monkey is exhausted it's perched on a
lower branch over a swamp the matcha
kanga and the park administration have
made a deal they help preserve the
ecosystem in return for certain benefits
the hunters keep a list of the animals
they beg basically the idea is that
communities can really have information
about how much they're hunting and what
the state of the populations are out in
the areas they're hunting are and then
hopefully they can think about taking
some decisions towards management of
that resource to ensure that it's there
forever the matcha Ganga contribute to
the maintenance of their ecosystem and
its biodiversity humans can be a part of
a functioning ecosystem but they can of
course disrupt it too and very fast so
Rob Williams and his team are always on
the lookout for changes they're
installing hundreds of motion or
infrared sensor cameras to get data on
animals that normally are almost
impossible to track the project is
partly funded by the German environment
ministry's international climate
initiative brockett deer come by as do
peccaries
this Jaguar has caught a caiman animals
that come out at night like this taper
also have their portraits taken but
there are still great secrets in the
rainforest groups of people who want
nothing to do with the outside world we
know as little about them as they know
about us it's also crucial for their
sake that the ecosystem in Meadow
National Park be preserved